Good morning and welcome.
My name is Mike Neville O'Neill and I'm the head of
product at Bronto, and today I'll be joined by
AO Mahoney,
uh, engineering manager from Teamwork.com.
Benoit is currently occupied with booth duty,
so you can check him out over at 1757.
And today we're going to be talking about logs
at scale without compromise.
So picture this, it's 3 a.m.,
something's on fire, and you need to figure out which
of the seven logging systems your company uses
the data resides in.
Is it in Cloudwatch? Is it in Elastic
or Greylog, or is it in the S3
bucket with all the Athena queries that nobody
remembers how to run?
Uh, if any of this sounds familiar to you,
you're not alone, and it's a symptom
of what we call the 3C flywheel of
compromises, and it starts with cost.
Uh, legacy logging solutions are prohibitively
expensive at scale.
Whether you're running a data dog or a new relic or
you're running something on-prem like a gray log
or elastic,
as soon as you hit scale,
cost becomes the major constraint
for every subsequent decision that you're able
to make.
Uh, the first thing that you're likely to do is to start
cutting retention of your data sources from
30 days to 7 days,
uh, maybe then to 3 days,
and once you've shortened retention as much as you can,
you start cutting data sources,
CDN data,
debug logs, anything that's remotely
considered noisy ends up
on the cutting room floor.
This invariably leads to coverage
gaps across your infrastructure, uh,
where it's essentially like trying to understand
a novel with several chapters torn out
of it. Um, teams notice
these coverage gaps and visibility is
still required into this data.
Just because it doesn't fit into your budget doesn't
make it any less business critical and
so teams invariably will spin up workarounds,
uh, in order to get visibility into this data
which leads to a proliferation of tools in
your environments,
uh, and increases. Cost not
just in terms of the cost of total
cost of ownership of the products,
um, but the cost of the friction as engineers
are trying to move across different tools with different
query languages, different retention policies,
uh, different access controls to stitch
together a cohesive picture of what actually
occurred in their environment.
This is the exact cycle that Bronto was
built to break.
So, what is Bronto?
Bronto is a logs first observability
platform where you can retain all of your data
for 12 months hot by default.
Um, we've been tested at petabyte scale
and although most of our customers are operating
in the multi-terabyte range, we're more
than ready for what's coming down the pike.
Um, we, the entry point is cents, not
dollars per gigabyte, and it's our efficient architecture
that enables this cost efficiency that I'll be talking
about a little bit down the line.
Um, we have exceptionally transparent usage and
billing. One of the biggest problems when
a bill is spiked in a logging platform
or an observability tool is understanding why
that spike occurred.
With Bronto, you always know why.
We can integrate with any agent. We do not
have a proprietary agent of our own,
so any telemetry agent you care to name
can be used to send data to Bronto,
whether that's a proprietary agent like a
new relic or a data dog, or it's an open
source collector like Otel or Fluent Bit.
Uh, if it speaks HTTP you can send logs
up to Bronto. You can even curl up parallel
world in your terminal if you so desire.
Um,
in terms of AI powered log management, the
AI features we have are available in shipping
and production today. This is not roadmap
theater. Everything that we're going to be seeing in the
presentation and the slides is on
product and ready for you to use.
Lastly, we're able to deliver subsecond
search against multi-terabyte sized
data sets
and our, our efficient search architecture
enables that capability, which I'll be talking
about in more detail in just a bit.
Here you can see a couple of aspects of our interface
on the left side of the
screen you'll see our dashboard which is providing
some visibility
into CDN data where we can see
cache hits by Pop,
uh, requests by geocountry, the sorts
of operational visibility that you would. Expect
from a tool like this
on the right we see the usage explorer
and this is what I was talking about earlier with transparent
billing and ensuring that you're no
surprises in terms of uh the
drivers of cost in your account.
So the usage Explorer is primarily designed
to help you answer
three questions. Number 1, how much
data am I ingesting?
Number 2,
what teams are ingesting that data? And number
3, is anybody actually using
the data that we ingest?
Uh, we give you visibility granularly
into search and ingestion metrics so you can figure
out, am I actually using the things that I'm
sending to Bronto
and make more informed decisions about the data
that you're choosing to keep in the platform.
Next, let's talk about features and capabilities.
Uh, here at Bronto we are obsessed
with reducing MTTR and removing
toil. Uh, we think that there are a number
of problems that LLMs can be applied
to, uh, to reduce the amount of work that
you have to do to make your data and your observability
tool of value, uh, starting
with AI dashboard creation where one of the
biggest pain points of. Using or
migrating to any new observability platform
is creating new dashboards, creating new widgets,
understanding the query language and how the platform
works.
Uh, we have a natural language dashboard
creation feature that gives you the ability
to, uh, specify a prompt
to get what you need. So it's really just as simple as
typing in,
show me all of my 500 errors across all
of my services and you're off to the races.
Speaking of reducing toil, we've also implemented
AI generated parsers.
Uh, we're able to automatically identify the
format of your data, create a parser for
it, and then apply it.
So there's really no more need for you
to be writing regular expressions or grok patterns,
uh, unless it's something that you want to
do. With pronto, it's no longer something that you
have to do.
AI
investigations are where we're bringing LLMs to bear along
with our context engineering and domain knowledge
to shorten the time that it takes to investigate
uh errors in your log data. Uh, we
go a lot further beyond than just explaining
what a particular error is. We
go towards understanding what. The source format
of that is what the key fields are, for
example, if we see a 500 error,
then the key fields might be something like client IP
endpoint,
uh, customer ID, and more. We'll automatically
launch queries across your data set in order
to build a coherent timeline of
what occurred.
Uh, suggest an RCA and also generate
additional queries for you to run to continue your
investigation to understand what the blast radius
is. So
with the error, uh, with the brontoscope
or the error explanation feature, you can
cut down your investigation time from 15
to 30 minutes to 15 seconds.
Statement IDs is something that is brand new
and is unique to Bronto, and it is
a technology that allows us to associate
a unique fingerprint, uh, with every log
message that you send to the platform.
This allows us to do a couple of different things.
One of the things that we can do is give you the ability to go
directly from a log line to
the code that generated it in GitHub.
Uh, this is incredibly powerful from going
from a monitor notification directly
to your code so that you can go straight from
finding to fixing.
The other piece where this becomes interesting is
if you're familiar with something called log patterns,
uh, where with statement IDs we can understand
which of those messages occur with the most frequency
and perhaps more interestingly which happened
with the least frequency. Where are my outliers?
Where are the new messages that I've never seen before?
Uh, why are messages changing in a sequence
or transaction, uh, where it's almost always
the same type of logs? All these
types of outliers can be, uh, identified
rapidly using statement ID.
This quarter we've also released distributed tracing,
uh, particularly around cross-service
correlation. Um, although we are logs
first, we are not logs only, we're not
zealots, and we believe that there is a place
for telemetry signals to live, uh, in our
platform
to kind of assist in getting to the log
data. Traces are exceptional
for understanding where something has broken,
and with the log data automatically correlated,
you can very easily understand why.
Um, this is a smaller thing, uh, but maybe
less small if you're trying to understand
a monitor definition at 3 a.m. with
bleary eyes, which is that we'll use AI
to automatically name,
uh, things like alerts, parsers,
dashboards, etc.
so that you're not required to come up with those convention
yourself. Next,
let's talk a little bit about how we built Bronto.
Uh, the first thing that's worth noting is that we built Bronto
entirely on AWS
and that our architecture decouples storage
for compute, which is really the key to
our cost efficiency.
Uh, I'll kind of take you through the diagram starting with ingest,
and we can see that data comes in over
HTTP via any of the agents
that you care to name that I discussed earlier,
uh, before streaming the EC2 instances
behind load balancers. From there we
stream the data to MSK where it's written
to S3 in a proprietary format.
I'll discuss in more detail in just a bit.
In terms of the web UI, uh,
and API, we're using a combination
of EC2
and Cloudfront to make those things available
to our customers.
Um, in terms of storage, we're obviously
using S3, but the way in which we're
using it is where we really start to diverge
from the other solutions that you see in the space.
Um, we actually write to S3 in a proprietary
format that's been optimized specifically
for log data,
uh, and this format makes use of all
of the techniques that you would expect from a modern analytics
engine, aggressive compression, columnar
storage, bloom filters, data
partitions, all built from the ground up
to return your logs to you as fast as they possibly
can be.
Um,
it's kind of this emphasis on, on,
uh, the proprietary format that
allows us to deliver speed in a way that, uh,
other tools cannot,
but storage isn't quite where it stops.
Uh, we, when we're talking about search, we have
to mention lambda as well, which in
many ways is the backbone of our query
experience in the sense that it allows us to
deliver incredible power but also
maintain exceptional cost efficiency by
avoiding overprovisioning.
So for example, when you run a query that needs
to scan a very large volume of data,
we have the ability to spin up lambdas in
parallel to process it.
Um, on the other hand, we are only
paying to use that compute when it is actually,
uh, being used or when the lambda is
actually active,
uh, and that gives us the ability to, uh,
be exceptionally cost efficient as well.
So. Essentially if you're running a query with
a large volume of data, we can
spin up hundreds of lambdas if needed
to query S3 concurrently
and get you those results as fast as we can
and because we're only paying for the compute that
we're using, uh, we can run a cost efficient
platform and maintain that cost advantage
and pass it on to you.
Uh, in terms of security,
uh, we're using Cognito for A verified
permissions for our back,
uh, and on the vulnerability management side of things
we're using inspector, uh,
as well as AWS guard duty,
um, in terms of kind of the, the cost model
that we've come up with, it's going to be a bit challenging
we think for other tools in this space to replicate
that, um, because the cost models
kind of inherently assume an expensive indexing
cost for every gigabyte that you send to them.
And we're built fundamentally differently, um,
to assume that the, the price for that should be,
uh, cents rather than dollars.
So what does this ultimately unlock?
Uh, what does it do for our customers?
I want to draw your attention to the lines that you see on
the graph here where the X axis represents
the size of the data set being queried in gigabytes
and the Y axis represents the duration
of the query in milliseconds and just
check out all of these lines. It really does. It doesn't matter what
you're doing, whether you're trying to count log
events, uh, detect a sequel injection
attack, find a rare UUID, that
classic needle in a haystack use case,
or list all the events with slow response times,
ultimately all these queries complete in under
500 milliseconds against a 5 terabyte
size data set.
This is the kind of performance and experience that our
architecture unlocks for you.
Um, but given where we are in the talk, I think
it's probably
better to hear directly from
what the benefits of bringing Bronto to teamwork
have been for him.
Thank you, Mike.
Morning, everybody. So,
uh, my name's E O'Mahony. I'm an engineering manager
at Teamwork.com.
Uh, we're based and then, we're founded
and headquartered in Cork in Ireland,
founded in 2007.
Uh, our founders, uh, Peter and Dan
ran an agency for several years
before that, so
they saw the need in the market for a project
management solution.
Um,
and they built out, uh, the teamwork suite, which
is easy to use project management with streamlined
operations. Uh, we were
very proud of being self-funded for years, but
the last few years we took on a big 70 million
investment to help us,
uh, scale the growth of the product and add really cool
new features into it.
And as of recently, we have over, uh,
20,000 customers worldwide,
and
having that many daily users is, uh,
the reason why we have logging challenges which
Bronto have been very helpful to help us solve.
Uh, so just another quick, uh, rundown what teamwork
is. So we're a project and resource management
product, uh, powered by AI built
for service teams,
or, um, it's to
help teams adopt quickly and get value from their,
uh, the work that they do in their business and make
sure that managers have,
sorry, yeah,
uh, make sure managers have, uh, key insights
into their financial performance. So it's all about getting work
done and getting paid to get the work done and leaving the friction
of the product to one side.
Uh, the, the main areas that we cover,
uh, project management was always the core of, uh,
of the product when launched, but over the years we've also
added in resource management and financial management,
uh, which when put together give real value to
customers.
And then we have some supporting features to the side. We have
reporting, we have integrations,
deep automations. More recently, AI
is a fundamental part, uh, of our product stack,
and we're shortly releasing a, a new gente
feature called Teammates, which will really help,
uh, give customers extra value with the product.
And dashboarding as well then for insights into
their usage.
And then as well we have uh Teamwork
desk, which is our help desk product and
it, it supports client communications,
B2B comms,
uh, spaces, is our
knowledge base and help and, uh, documentation
store. And a recent product we added as well is
Teamwork Connect, which is a way for customers to integrate
their own. Uh,
BI tooling directly into our teamwork data
again to get better insights.
And the overall aim is to give,
uh, insights into increased billable utilization
and improved profitability,
helping customers to get the work done, to
get the team's, uh,
work build, and then to, er, iterate
on that,
er, each month through the rest of the year.
So, uh, our logging challenges before Bronto
came along, uh, we have a conflict infrastructure.
It's a mix of self-hosted open source, uh,
cloud-based and custom solutions,
uh, with a lot of difficult query, structured and unstructured
data,
indexing issues. We
roughly have about 33 terabytes
of logs a day, uh, sorry, a month, uh, being
ingested, billions of logs from different
systems.
Um,
that require, that causes over operational
overheads.
Uh, we operate in 3 AWS
regions, so we're a big AWS customer,
uh, 2 production regions in the US
and the EU region, and then, uh, replicated,
um, staging set up,
uh, for testing.
Uh, so that requires a lot of ongoing maintenance
when you have a lot of self-hosted systems. So
things like Greylog, having to replicate Greylog
configurations into all these different accounts is,
is
time consuming.
Uh, we had limited coverage.
So,
uh, the two main systems we were using were
for our customer traffic
that was coming in,
traffic logs. We were using uh
CloudWatch,
but we had retention rules and Cloudwatch which only retained
about 2 weeks' worth of data for cost reasons,
which is a challenge and because you just don't have a long-term
view. On the developer's side, everything was
going into a giant grey log store which was
backed up by open search.
Again, because of costs, you have to set a limit
on your open search node sizes,
which effectively turns it into a first in, first out
log store.
Very noisy teams would end up
er expiring logs, so you could never really
rely on having a long-term view of your logs.
Um,
and you just had no real insight into which team was using
the log allocation.
Cost inefficiency then, operating all this stuff was
very expensive, even though it was very, it wasn't
very heavily customer facing, so it wasn't giving
sort of direct value to customers, but it was costing
a lot of money to run it. So it was good for operating
the business but not for customer er
features.
And it was inefficient and it, it was just brittle.
So that's where Bronto came along.
So, what we have now with Bronto, simplicity,
um, the unified logging solution has
replaced a ton of legacy tools like Grey log
and the cloudwatch logs, custom solutions.
We've no index management.
We don't have breaking open search indexes
anymore. Uh, we have a much longer
retention, so standard 90 day retention, 12
month retention for our customer traffic logs, so we get
really good detail of our,
uh, long-term customer behavior.
Uh, we've been able to save
42% just in software costs
by switching to Bronto. So that doesn't include
the maintenance effort, but, uh, freeing up our sys
ops engineers who have to maintain these,
these custom solutions.
Um. And
when we were doing comparisons
of Bronto to other SAS solutions,
some of the other providers, their ingest cost alone
was gonna cost more than
the entire operational cost of Bronto for the year.
So they're, they're, from a price point, it was very,
uh, a very positive experience.
And then some of the new features we have now with Bronto we
never had before, so the Team Explorer,
uh, the usage Explorer, it gives us very good detail
into what teams are actually creating the logs and where
the, the usage actually is in the system.
And the bigger one as well is we can actually
put the logging.
UX in front of teams and staff that
are not very technically,
er, er experienced or
or confident, so support teams,
uh, product managers can now interrogate logs
in a much easier way and it, it reduces the burden on
engineers to have to do all that preparatory work,
uh, to provide, uh, logging outputs.
So all in all, it's a great experience. And as well, the other
quick thing is just the customer experience of dealing with the guys.
Any changes, we've asked for feature additions. They've been very
responsive to make them.
They've they've just been a dream to deal with, so it's been a really great
experience. Back
to Mike Thanks
very much, Ay. Uh,
appreciate your time and attention today. If you've liked what
you've heard, come over and talk to us over at booth
1757.
Uh, you can also sign up for a free trial
at Bronto.io. No credit card
required.
Thanks again. Have a good day.